people think that the world is in chaos
people think that the world is on fire
right now and for all the wrong reasons
I think that's partly because of how we
consume information but also because
there is a segment of politician to try
to scare us to get because then we
clamor for safety we need the strong man
away
I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Johan Norberg he's a
Swedish economist and social theorist
and his most recent book is progress in
progress
I mean you lay out an absolutely
convincing case that most things are
getting much much better what are the
things that are getting better and
what's guiding that kind of progress
well basically the world is getting
better a society economy culture
politics is not getting better so it was
really a book about how I get depressed
- all the time especially when I follow
the news about what politicians do and
how they try to stifle Liberty this is a
book about what people do what mankind
does when we have freedom to explore
strange new ideas and exchange the
results and then what we see is like I
mean in the last 25 years we've invented
that have been considered as sort of
neoliberalism capitalism run amok what
has happened well we've reduced chronic
undernourishment around the world by 40%
child mortality and illiteracy by by
half and extreme poverty from 37 to 10%
so every minute that we're talking 100
people right gonna pop down you said
though that you know politics it's not
getting better and there's a lot of
reason to believe that certainly in
Europe we're seeing from it from a
libertarian point of view we're seeing a
rise of nativist kind of xenophobic
groups to kind of turn to a fascist
right which that's a kind of a fascist
lasting using countries as varied as
Hungary and Italy and France is what's
going on with that and is it how is it
connected to these other improvements
yeah in a way I wrote this book not
because I'm happy about the world but
because I'm terrified about what's going
on because people think that the world
is in chaos people think that the world
is on fire right now for all the wrong
reasons I
think that's partly because of how we
consume information but also because
there is a segment of politicians who
try to scare us to get because then we
clamor for safety we need the strong man
in a way so I think that people who are
afraid they aren't tolerant they aren't
liberal they don't accept people moving
across borders trade going on in and
national where they afraid of but you
know and and and the book is fantastic
and we've talked about it in the past
but if a lifespan like your grandparents
lifespan at birth was thirty and you're
living to be 71 what would Y would you
be susceptible to somebody saying oh
everything's getting [ __ ] up why are
people suckers for tales that say you
know we're like we are one you know
blown the circuit breaker from a
complete collapse of society yeah
it doesn't Bryce me too but in a way I
think it's because we have so much to
lose we now have this comfortable
lifestyle but the world seems a bit
strange we don't understand really
what's going on and I think that it's
partly two sides of the same coin and
because people who live comfortable
lives they only think about what they've
got to lose when I go to Vietnam when I
go to China when I go to India I meet
optimistic people who think about all
the new business models technologies
that can improve their lives when I go
to the US and Europe people are so
depressed and so scared about what's
going on and then they're following the
news and then they see they don't notice
that homicide has been haft in 20 years
they notice one serial murderer on the
loose summer and then with social media
we see it all the time combine that with
terrorism the financial crisis in a new
geopolitical situation people are
confused and when they're confused
they're scared and they want a strong
man who gives them well I think you're
you know your book goes a long way to
explaining and painting and it's not
even it's not what is now in America
known as alternative facts it's the
actual facts but I was thinking while
you were talking about Donald Trump is
obviously a master of injecting a
negative pessimistic narrative in which
the only solution is him as the great
men coming in and solve everything and
it was fascinating
after decades of declines in crime and
violent crime property crime crime every
sort of crime and there have been some
minor up ticks in the past couple of
years and it's not clear if it's a trend
yet but he was able to campaign on being
a law and order candidate which was the
type of candidate you had in the late
60s and early 70s when crime actually
was rapid rapidly growing and it was
ubiquitous particularly in cities but
then I guess the question is you know
who why would anybody buy that because
it's you know you've know in your own
life that you're walking around a city
like Washington DC even 20 years ago
there were large large part so that you
just couldn't walk around in and now
it's you know people have you know
gourmet dog biscuits tours in places
that you would have blood cracking it
ends up I mean is that what the role
that politics is playing now is it it
kind of feeds off the success that's
happening outside of politics or beyond
politics and then it's trying to pull it
into its orbit when the way we
discovered if you go back to the
Industrial Revolution that was the
moment in history when we discovered
poverty when we discovered child labor
and began to complain about those things
and asking politicians why can't you
deal with those things not because those
things increase but for the first time
they actually decrease so people began
to think that I can live a decent
comfortable life so if there are
problems like that it's somebody's fault
this is a huge problem that we have to
deal with I think that's going on with
with things like crime as well when
would you take it for granted it's like
you have to live your life and you just
get on with it
now it's an exception and then you want
someone to be in charge of it and deal
with they don't be a feel of populism
they they can give you all those
pie-in-the-sky things we'll deal with
that and you would agree that something
similar it might not be exactly the same
but something similar is showing up in
Europe as well and that it's not an
accident that it's in relatively wealthy
countries that we see this that's right
it's the kind of collapse anxiety when
you have a good life and it's kind of a
luxury good right and in the sense of
for poorer countries don't quite you
know they can't afford to be dilute
themselves yeah yeah the old things if
you don't have food you have one problem
if you have food you have thousands of
problems right that's a I never heard
that saying before but I'm getting I'm
going to use it for the rest of my day
at least want to rest of my life with
rest named entity well you know because
we're at this students for liberty
conference which brings in 2000 students
from all over the world who are
interested in kind of classical liberal
and libertarian ideas where do you find
them or when you talk to young people or
how do you do young people have a good
grasp of the history that is necessary
to contextualize current problems to
move towards a more libertarian future
or you know are they pessimistic I
really think that children are future
have that I've heard before that's the
old xanga and definitely when it comes
to trusting politicians because you have
no one trusts politicians everybody
hates what's going on in Washington or
or Brussels but there is more of a
tendency among an older court to think
that all those politicians fail so let's
just elect an even stronger guy who can
solve these problems with an even bigger
solution whereas I find more of cynicism
when it comes to that among the young
particles they've seen how technology
and their own ways of organizing
solutions to their problem is something
that's being done voluntarily in in
society rather than then through
politics and when you look at this rise
of populism around the were up in the
u.s. most of the voters are the old ones
it's the old baby boomers who are now
retiring and thinking that there must
have been a good old days when I was
young and let's don't Trump speaks to
that he tells you that look we can go
back to this but when America was great
back to the 50s and so on I don't see
that in the jungle generation and they
don't vote for the populous as much as
being it their parents is cynicism is
that dangerous though because it does it
hardened people and make them disengage
not just in politics which would be one
thing but do they disengage from kind of
people like Peter teal if talked about
this from creating the future
you know that maybe they become
complacent and they think the future
will just take place on its own and they
won't be as active player in that I
don't see that I see the the strongest
tendencies that Bengal had installed
problems young younger generation see as
many problems at all the people do but
they've got a knack for it you know they
are used to another way of dealing with
things it's not trying to work through a
political system and then becoming
disappointed when nothing happens
because other people have other
priorities and then you want the strong
men to just solve the problem they are
used to doing it in other ways consumer
society and produce a society they do
think that's at least a major tenant so
instead of arguing in front of the taxi
Commission to increase the number of
cars on the road at any one point they
create over height okay well we will
leave it there though I think that's a
great note to end it on Thank You Johann
we've been talking with Cato Institute
Johan Norberg he's an author and social
theorist this most recent book is
progress at the international students
for liberty conference thanks so much
for talking Johan
for reason TV I'm Nicholas
[Music]